season 21 of america is [ __ ] dope
it's crazy man like this this first like
these first few episodes are
crazy it really is and you know you know
what i mean my boy we're talking about
is he was like bro now
he said watch a waterfall and wall
street needs another bailout
and then biden has a tough decision to
make
does he bail out does he bail out his
suits
or does he take care of the people that
are all [ __ ] up from the pandemic
because you know the the loss could be
so big that it's
uh he has to pick you might not be able
to service both
yeah so you know i i also just think
it's the
ultimate irony that it's [ __ ] game
stop
like oh yeah everything comes back to
gamers
everything in the world right now gaming
is the epicenter of
everything in the world and
i mean i i just i thought it was so
funny
the ultimate irony was that it's game
stop stealing everybody's money
because they've been doing that for the
[ __ ] ever when they
take your shitty game and they sell it
for 45
and they gave you one for it no but this
is like they're not
they're not stealing money they're
stealing money from the rich and giving
it to the poor
i mean the robin hood at this point yeah
that was the best tweet i think this
morning is that robin hood is actually
robin hood
it's so so funny god this whole thing is
poetic it truly is
the best tweet i saw was someone saying
that uh deep [ __ ] value that guy so
if you don't know we're talking about
just go on wall street bets and read
about gme
yeah everything basically basically yeah
you want to explain it yeah basically
this this dude
what's his was his username again deep
[ __ ] value
deep [ __ ] value so a year ago he
makes this post
on wall street bets about how he
believes gamestop is oversold
it's a very intense thread and i've seen
threads like this on wall street bets
and
i could see you reading it and being
like yeah there's some good arguments
here but whatever
he's basically saying like it's the next
blockbuster
it's going to zero and so i mean
at least all these hedge funds think
that it is so they've all shorted it
yeah and they've taken crazy short
positions
but there's not enough of the stock or
whatever right
yeah so so he buys options
you know basically betting that gamestop
in fact will go positive and
by the way we don't really know [ __ ]
about this we're just this is honestly
to help
me learn just uh like repeating what
i've been reading
yeah you know i don't really know [ __ ]
about the market i'm not really
smart like that but well this is yeah
this is our stupid explanation yeah and
this is like the most i've gathered so
basically
he he basically looks at gamestop and he
says nah man
i think this this there's some money to
be made here and if you want to put it
simply
so he buys options betting that the
value of gamestop
stock will increase
no he buys options you know
on the premise that the value of the
stock will increase that's
that's how he'll make money so it
increases and it gets them up to 54 gs
and everyone goes
damn bro 50k
good for you yeah and then
there's like a whole series of drama
that takes place after that where
essentially it seems like
wall street bets kind of takes note of
all these hedge funds
betting against gamestop and then it
becomes a thing of like
ah [ __ ] the system bro at least that's
kind of what i'm thinking
like they see all these options
contracts and they go nah [ __ ] that like
well basically like they they wanted to
like short squeeze the stock which means
that there's way too many people
they think that shorted it and if they
can run the stock price up a little bit
then the people that shorted it are left
scrambling because they have to cover
their positions so they
buy the stock again to cover their
position so they don't lose too much
money
which runs the price up even more which
squeezes
the people that have the short positions
even more that haven't covered yet and
the whole thing is just this giant
cycle which rockets the stock price up
right and
and so what's really funny about that is
it it snowballed to the point of
billions [ __ ]
billions bro yeah to the point of one of
the traditionally
uh best performing hedge funds ever
is down like 20 to 30 percent as of
yesterday and they had to
they had to get a bailout from one of
the free
basically three billion dollars
because they're losing so much money
because they had such a big short
position
on gamestop and now they might be
bankrupt
people don't know but so what's
essentially happened is you have this
and
you know the the assets under management
of this hedge fund is like 50
what was it 20 billion or something like
that 15 billion
that's just been basically distributed
to
wall street best people sort of right
i don't know that's that's what that's
my i mean that kid's deep [ __ ] value
is sitting on what like close to 30 mil
off this whole thing yeah i think 30
million now as of today so he
bought options for how much in the
beginning um
i thought seven thousand dollars yeah i
think it was he was going to make 54
grand he went from 54 000 profit
to 30 million to 30
30 million dollars and so the best tweet
that i saw
was someone saying that guy should buy
the miami house owned by the dude who
owns melvin capital
and then open a game stop on it
holy [ __ ] man because basically
everyone's like [ __ ] the system because
you know while or these these big hedge
fun owners have been doing these same
tactics
for years and [ __ ] over the average
investor
just trying to make a living the big so
now we're doing it to them basically
and the big thing the big squeeze the
short what was it the short king squeeze
or whatever
yeah yeah someone tweeted at us you know
the you could actually call this like
the short kings yeah you know
bro watch it watching jim cramer
who you know he's like an investment
like you know
he has a show fast money whatever look
it up
watching jim cramer like sort of like
like being forced to acknowledge reddit
and watching him talk about it is so
funny yeah like because his audience
doesn't use the internet like that so
him having to parse that information
yeah to his audience and he himself
doesn't really get it
it's so [ __ ] good i love when people
refer to it as a forum
a forum it's a forum i mean i guess it
is a forum but it's so
far from the forums that the actual
forums that we used to use
remember [ __ ] real forums yeah yeah
nothing's organized it's just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show every thread is
ridiculously just
uploaded about everything you can't find
anything
you can only read like nine comments a
page yeah everyone's got goofy profile
pictures and signature
it's just like email threads it was
really stupid and
yeah reddit is so far from a forum
i mean you know people on forums at
least took showers
people on reddit nah it's just they're
in that hoe
eating attendees eating tendees man
wall street vets has eaten attendees
tonight bro that's the funniest the deep
[ __ ] values to just post a picture of
like
dino nuggets like frozen dino nuggets
like a hundred of them
coming out of the oven and putting them
on his [ __ ]
seven million dollar home you know in
hawaii
looking out at the water and he's like
tendy time boys
and here's the thing it's like people on
wall street bets are saying it's going
game stock stock is going to a thousand
it's going to a thousand we're gonna
squeeze this thing all the way up
which if that actually happens this
dude's gonna have what a nine figure ten
figure
net worth right what is a hundred
million bucks what is that one two three
four five six seventy nine nine
but imagine that you go from seventy
thousand to a hundred million dollars
stu could buy infinite attendees oh
so you can go to chick-fil-a buy as many
nuggets as you want
you can then go to mcdonald's you can go
to just go to costco get the biggest bag
of frozen attendees you possibly
he needs to start a youtube channel of
just draining tendees
from various fast food chains that's all
it is like he just pulls up to a burger
king he's like y'all got chicken nuggets
they say yeah he's like i want him
they go okay how many he's like no i
want all of them
how many bags you got i don't know like
six all right what's the weight on it
like 25 pounds per fry them all
i'm taking him with me yeah he just
turns into a 10d review channel
yeah and he's got he's got like that
like a like a 250
000 like six-wheel mercedes truck yeah
yeah
yeah i don't know how to browse that
brabus i've always called it bravo's
robust yeah i don't know the bra bus
because that's what that [ __ ] is the
bang bus yeah no it's the bra bus that
dude drives down the street it's like
that's the tindy man
they take out their [ __ ] bronzers
throwing that [ __ ] [ __ ] playing music
yeah it's like an ice cream truck it's
the tandy man the dandy man
this just all hot girls
oh my god it's the tendy man
in the middle of the street on melrose
and he slithers out the sunroof with
this [ __ ] worm ass and pale ass body
and he's reached down he's like who
wants attendee and he just starts you
know he's like me
and they're throwing the bras back at
him and he collect
that's how you pay yeah one bra five
attendees
no no it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
girls it would just be other wall street
bets dudes
yes and one tindy for you
and one did teddy for you my brother one
two three
and they're all wearing rocket ship
t-shirts to the moon
to the moon to the moon
give me cindy d [ __ ] value yeah
we are not worthy dfvd
we were trying to get someone from wall
street best to jump on the podcast and
explain this better than we could
because there's probably a lot we're
missing and we probably we probably
[ __ ] up what's really going on but
that's all the gist of it and that's as
far as i understand it
all you guys need to know is that some
people are rich as [ __ ] today
loaded and i mean it's not over it's
still going up yeah
yeah should we check let me just peep
real quick
it's like i
i feel like this is one of those things
where the volatility is just
out of control here we go luke yeah 316.
yes luke that's what 3 16.
316 bucks now it was four dollars like
months ago
it's up 100 today dude
it was four dollars last august it's up
fourteen
it's up eight thousand percent
bro look at that dow jones down 480
points right now
this chick is affecting the entire
market i mean that's the crazy
that's right it has more value
it has more value than i think alaska
airlines or some [ __ ]
it was the most traded
yesterday more than tesla
[Laughter]
[ __ ] gamestop
dude it's worth more than alaska air
group yeah
dude gamestop was worth more than
[ __ ] airplanes
that is killing me yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] wild
holy [ __ ]
what kind of asses do you guys have we
have airplanes that's cool
we just got a bunch of guys that like
chicken tenders behind us
the power of attendees oh man i was
howling
at this post directed at wall street on
wall street bets
i was [ __ ] crying an open letter to
cnbc
before you spend another day hosting
your shill hedge fund buddies to come on
the air and demonize wall street bets i
hope you read this
your contempt for the retail investor
parents your audience
is palpable and if you don't get it
together you'll lose an entire new
generation of investors
i keep thinking about these funds that
are short gme like your boys at melvin
capital slash
your coverage of the subreddit and i'm
getting madder and
these funds can manipulate the market
via your network and if they screw up
big because they don't even know the
basics of portfolio risk 101
and using in using position sizing they
just get a bailout from their
billionaire friends at citadel
then they have the nerve to turn us into
public enemy number one just because we
believe in an underdog company
getting a second chance we don't have
billionaires to bail us out when we mess
up our portfolio risk and position goes
against us
we can't go on tv and make attempts to
manipulate millions
to take our side of the trade if we mess
up as bad as they did we're wiped out
have to start from scratch and are back
to giving hand jobs behind the dumpster
at wendy's
seriously [ __ ] these people i
sincerely hope they suffer we want to
see the lost porn
[Laughter]
lost porn dude if this [ __ ] squeezes and
all those contracts execute oh my god
they're gonna print
that stock like the
the chart on a t-shirt
i can't it's also
i mean the part about them believing
that an underdog company is going to
have a second chance is kind of [ __ ]
right um wait wait say again he said
just because we believe in an underdog
company having a second chance
oh that is no one that thinks stop is
coming back it's complete horse
get the [ __ ] out of here with that sorry
i just i just had to read the whole
thing because i thought it was just
it's too funny yeah